hey guys W that's us we're here yeah
that's you you can lead oh so we're
going to be playing a little bit of uh
World of Warcraft Warlords of dror we
got into the alpha and I know a lot of
people have been looking and oh yeah
it's a beta now is it yeah since last
Friday and we're going to be giving out
some codes that people are going to be
able to to get a hold of but right now
we we have an early code so we're going
to try it out some and and see what this
all is about um I have not gotten to try
it out myself I know I have a I have a
Cod at home and I'm waiting to get into
this have you spent any time with the
alpha so far uh beta no only only just
creating models just to do our videos to
show everyone what the new models look
like let's just jump straight into it
yeah cuz they've revamped almost all of
the models but not all of them are in
the game yet they've been kind of
teasing out which ones are are different
so far yeah and there's still some to go
yeah and they've done like male human
but it's not in the game right now they
haven't implemented everything even some
of these animations for the redone ones
are not complete yet but uh yeah human
female let's see let's get a closeup on
this face here we go hairstyle
sure as you can see much better I don't
know you yeah it's you have to look at
the old models side by side when you
look at them side by side a much more
drastic change especially with the
animations and everything um but just
graphically things are there there is an
improvement oh yeah especially with this
look at this when was the last time they
did that graphical Improvement was it
back in it
wasn't Improvement for what for for the
game itself there was a there was a
slight upgrade was it really oh oh think
you're talking about yeah exactly
cataclysm they changed things around and
they just made it a better looking world
and it was so much work for them that
that was like one of the worst
expansions actually no the worst
expansion for a while uh I burning
Crusade is still hard to go back to
really for for me it is yeah because
it's difficult but this is so much of a
grind whereas whereas the later
expansions I feel like they've made it
much more of a game and trying to change
things up so it's not just like go kill
five or 10 of these things yeah true I I
think I think that was the best
expansion
though are there any of the the
characters that look different now that
that you feel like look a lot better oh
yeah all of them all it's somewhat
debatable I think some people were
mentioning that they liked the old
female orc better I think it might be
just because they they made it so much
more detailed now that you can actually
see how ugly she is kind
of whereas it was a little more bland
before she's a Eric's going to hate me
for that cuz this was strong this was
his his right here yeah we hear
Eric Tay off screen going
hater I I've always been an alliance
player I know that that is not the
popular choice among kids these days but
kids yeah it was popular choice among
kids back in the day the very first but
then everybody moved over to horde so I
was like now I'm all alone but fine
because now my server's
quiet a lot of servers are quiet now I
think I don't know I haven't played
since early miss the pandar I think
Toren Toren look awesome look at
that you can't quite see the hair I mean
it's not it's this is not a taxing on
your on your system to to make these
characters they just they look better
they look more in line with what a game
should look like these days yeah without
going really crazy oh look at that look
at my old video
rolling
we have sound on there too probably no
sound but the the comparison between the
characters
is not not drastic but like that it's
tweaked enough that when you especially
looking side by side but just looking at
the new characters like this looks more
like a modern game and not like
EverQuest yep yep and uh yeah they they
didn't have to be too drastic with the
model changes cuz they didn't want to
piss people off and really if they if
they went too drastic with it uh they
would have to redo the whole Eng for the
game you know how massive the game is so
what character are we going to start
with today we are going to do a male
torren M Toren oh and one thing I wanted
to point out if we want to go back to
this screen is that you notice how like
the face
M if you scroll down each face like the
modeling is pretty much the same all
that changes is the skinning I don't
know if they're going to keep it like
that they kind of did that with like
wargan and some of the new model like P
pandarin mhm uh or any of less work on
their part to this but I
understand that's the way it's always
been though I guess I wouldn't have
expected it to be that different yeah
okay so let's get in let's get in this
game so I I'm actually curious so your
character here is fuzzy wuzzy when you
actually play the game are you one of
those people who just like makes
ridiculous names for your characters are
you someone who's like no no it has to
be it has to fit with the game in the
world uh it used to be a total dweeb and
I would name them after like anime
characters like this one this is
actually one of my characters um now I
do stupid names like thisy that shorty D
shorty D shorty fuzzy Wuzzy was someone
I used to play with and I just yeah I
don't I don't think too much I've had
some friends that that just pisses off
like when they see my character is like
Cow Town comes into town oh they get all
what are you on a role playing server or
something no no oh no yeah I'm not one
of those people yeah how how dare
they all right so we're basically going
to be starting from the beginning this
is right after you get in the dark
portal as you can see these stairs have
not rendered yet that's a
bug and this is early this is not the
the final game of course I want to tell
them the lore behind this why we're here
um so what I understand of the lore as
much as I I've been reading into this um
we're apparently going back in time and
we're going to explore the the
creation fat fingered that Windows key
yeah we're we're going to get to see the
the creation basically of of The Horde
and how the the trolls and all of this
started right yep yeah pretty much well
Orcs yeah Orcs yeah it's going to be
mainly centered on the Orcs uh right now
we're figh fighting the iron horde
which is uh a horde that garage you
remember garage you know yeah he's
making his own horde I guess these are
all the hord of uh the Orcs it's really
hard to play and talk at the same time
these are all the Orcs of the past and I
guess he's rallying them all to do his
own version of The Horde can we get a
like what's what's going on out here can
we get a look at the battlefield oh yeah
oh nice take look I can't fly around by
the way this mounts only until you get
to max level oh oh yeah I forgot that
they had added that in maybe not even I
think like a few months
after uh max level is even but yeah but
a little bit after that like after the
game goes live they're just going to
reintroduce that right so that for
people that that come into this world is
beginning they're only going to have
regular mounts but for everybody after
the after a few months then flying
mounts are going to open up yeah I think
they're I think they're undecided
actually they're kind of undecided on
whether or not to allow people to to fly
or not because when you fly you know
there's a lot less uh people running
into each other and you know that makes
the world team kind of empty when you're
just flying around everywhere not
interacting with other people not
getting in
fights oh finish this Bob Jones 1980
says please turn on your title turn on
my title no shut
op what
happened
okay oh I click this to complete now wow
okay oh you can just complete on the
that's how long it's been since I played
I don't know if they've already done a
to SP
spires sorry if you guys want to read
the story I am just going to go straight
in the more run yeah you're going to
have to get into that on your
do do you when you play do you actually
read through all of those or you just
like click click click oh yeah I know
just click click otherwise takes so long
to level if you're just going to read
everything there there's usually a point
like I'll read some of it but I feel
like if I if I'm just in the town where
I don't care about anything yeah then uh
but like at the beginning of it I always
read all the little things and find out
what's going on how I just say what is
this you should jump find out jump in go
up there and jump in suiciding you
already to go up there yeah go up there
it's like a ride it's like
Disneyland oh everyone is so happy that
we're playing beta just to do these kind
of shenanigans all right I'm just going
to jump in jump jump oh no I can't
invisible wall oh invisible wall stupid
all right how do I disable
these one is this
way oh yeah Ricky guitar says the
reasoning is also that they want people
to enjoy the artwork and not just fly
over everything oh
yeah good point Ricky yeah oh that's all
I did just clicked him I don't know what
he said uh he said L stuff someone
thanks you all right I think one thing
that wow has definitely gotten better
with over the years is is making the
game that's more interactive with its
story and not just like read a couple of
the text bubbles and then go on and oh
yeah and some were some MMOs that I've
been playing recently still rely on that
like not making it a part of the game
and making it just here's a side thing
which you can ignore completely
yeah like you can still ignore all this
but but I like that it's part of the
world that you you might find it
interesting because it's not completely
irrelevant it's not just a click to to
finish let me turn in the pelts and give
me the new
pants getting
Agro some things never change
so what quest are you on
now on slots end this is what our second
Quest all I did was click on a few
things this is going to be a long stream
if people are just going to watch me
Quest but that is the game we can well
we can explore stuff too we don't have
to yeah
true they should be sending me out of
this area soon though we don't have to
play by their
rules a tiger we can just rule this
game do you want to talk about Garrison
cuz I don't know if we'll get to that
point in the game yeah so Garrison I I
think are one of the more interesting
additions that at some point that we get
to to take part in this where you you
get to build your own town basically
right and other people will be able to
see it and interact with it to to a
limited
degree yeah I don't I don't know how
that works you have to invite them in
you yeah you I think you do have to to
invite people like you're going to be
able to find other characters in the
world and bring them into this and and
have them populate your town but it's
not something where like everybody's
going to be able to see it because that
would just be ridiculous like there's
there's not enough space in the world
for that to to exist but when you invite
people in then they'll be able to see
your town and kind of what you're what
you're specializing in oh I might be
mixing a wild star now I that's I was
playing that recently too where you can
also do kind of a town building thing
yeah cuz people have been wanting player
housing for forever and that's just sort
of their answer for it and giving you a
way to to customize the world the the
world that you see not necessarily the
world that everybody sees but you will
be able to to see other
people's if they invite you in where is
the soul
engine I'm right on top of you into all
this so this is thing you have to jump
into right yeah right but there's an
invisible wall and do I have to go there
we have to go up
there just fly there lot of
people look for the L God
I don't it's up here all right let's see
here I really don't think this is it by
the way because there's no direct path
but this is what you do in MOS it's a
secret path is that you start scaling
this there we go see we made it and then
seeing where it takes you I can't get up
there and now I'm
stuck oh yeah I'm stuck hold on I'm
climbing oh this is like old school W
right here all's weak
where am I
now and made
a that's
great that's that it just bring you back
you don't get to explore that well is
there a way to get up from here cuz
we're already on top maybe if you just
hang hang it right from the top hang a
right go like go back up the
stairs and hang a hang a right here is
there a way to nope I mean same issue
right yeah okay you know what let's
actually read this damn
thing you by Powers neither mechanical
nor Arcane look to either side of us the
souls of those
PL way into the chamber beneath
us okay I guess you got to go under
somewhere that's the
thing about these uh it can be little
indicators they they don't tell you
everything I guess because there's so
many levels you remember before they had
them though that was oh yeah you
actually had to you definitely had to
read it though or you had to put on a
mod I guess we're not going to be
exploring until we figure this
out okay just look at me jump around
that's what wow was for me just jumping
around
everywhere Where Do We Go
sir
near readed WTF is read haha Julio salty
yeah I am someone help me someone in
chat come on I know you guys
play I think we were on the right
track no we're not I don't know where
the hell I'm going oh this is this is
definitely not right we're going to get
transported back I'm I'm exploring I'm
exploring though can you jump off you
see that's where I'm going to get
transported
probably why is it quiet
yeah
but what about on the right side maybe
it's clear oh and look server shut down
in seven oh this is freaking awesome all
right let's just kill
stuff hold on let me try to
find look at this dude so
Alpha you know it's a good thing we all
played this before we got on stream
right oh yeah you know we're we were
super prepared it's it's been a busy
week and
weekend
suak Tumi says I liked while before they
added all the pointy arrows leading you
to request you'd be like reading
schmeing then be all lost till you read
the damn
thing like now yeah they have helped me
not and now L serers yeah I
know hopefully not for that long it
might just be one server actually I'm on
the PVP realm right now and then we're
just going to read Wikipedia entries
about the game
oh there used to be those uh those sites
we used to go to to see where to go
thoughtbot thoughtbot wad you remember
those yeah you would enter coordinates
to tell you where to go well that that
was the only way to figure out I felt
like some of these quests like it was
just so obtuse and it's like I don't
want to actually spend hours exploring
the the world to figure these things out
I just want you to tell me what to do
yeah where the hell do I go Jesus Christ
oh f finger that Windows key again I got
to disable that
oh zoom in on your mini map cuz we don't
even see it right now on the mini map or
maybe zoom out till we see the mark oh
we're zoomed out all the way so it's
more talking about this no no your Upp
right hand corner your mini map up
there and it's not really going to show
up up
there 5 minutes to figure this out we
can do this in five minutes or I will
like Q for wor on GL right
now are we over it on the map
now people are calling where's the love
for pandas let me see some of that no I
like I like the
P thought they were a fun addition so
there was a story recently where a guy
had leveled up to to I think it was 90
maybe 80 as completely neutral like he
never chose a faction he just stayed in
in Pandera the entire time yeah and you
saw how he did it right yeah
just by Mining and and herbing picking
flowers and Mining which it's sounds
really really boring I it's impressive
no it is impressive he got a lot of Nord
for it so more power to him he did what
South Park did there's got to be a way
to climb up there right yeah you know
there must be but I don't really see
it I could fly this would be so much
easier why wouldn't they just let me
jump in here and I wonder if it it might
be because this thing is bugged because
it's not rendering is that why jump up
this is this always this short
yes well there's a whole line of people
above you like walking into it so they
have to be coming from somewhere like
you can see him lining up and walking
along that path at the top
yep heart uh hul Leo says
pandas okay so that that expansion was
actually pretty well done and and the
only reason why I didn't keep playing it
was because I played wow for so long
that it was still just basically the
same so is that when you quit is that
when you kind of yeah pretty much quit
for like longer than a month yeah oh
look at that is this going to bring you
back let's go through here right if I
don't
fall but you know how direct quests are
this can be right if like if there's no
obvious path to it it's not the right
way but if it's a
solution
yeah oh no oh this sucks just charge up
yeah just charge up here come on no no
line of sight
really I think I can jump up that now
actually nope I don't have the time and
now they're all gone so people after
this are going to go watch a Persona
stream we could play Persona just going
to jump off this thing suicide what the
game wants me to do yeah obviously this
is the place to go yeah where
everybody we're
professionals oh what do you do this to
me this just
Hearthstone you think there's ever going
to be a point where they mix Hearthstone
into the game proper so like you don't
even have to leave the game to play
Hearthstone you just like go into an end
that'd be interesting if you could just
go to a Tavern and start playing with
other people play Hearthstone while
you're waiting then you would have to
sub to wow in order to do
that no you it's just something for Wild
players to do yeah yeah while buing
yourself I guess so maybe a little
simplified version okay
so I'm sure this is not going to be the
final version but how I got to that area
to begin with was to talk to this huge
dude which is
Kadar just say the word the
word and now I'm
here basically just waiting for that
minute to come and then seeing what is
going to happen with this
stream world's a obviously a little
buggy but there's got to be some way to
figure this out
yeah I I I think that it's probably more
that we're terrible at this and not that
it's yeah you
know
been so
long are we just so infatuated with this
little hole that we think that's what
the soul engine is but we see everyone
suiciding into it right I think that's
what the quest is talking about they're
Soul enging they're powering the soul
engine seems like a a logical conclusion
right we got oh there's a there's a door
got halfe oh really right there this is
got to be it this is right below
them there we go yay goldan
you know I think I think Tay in the
background said I said
that maybe you should have come out of
here then Eric we discovered the soul
engine you know maybe if everything
wasn't so you know unrendered I would
have seen this
easier second to me was saying time to
bring Max in again who saved us during
our last stream oh really what happened
oh we were playing PaRappa the Rapper
and um Peter and I were are terrible at
the game so he just came in and one
shotted one of the levels
nice just complet like dominated the
first time through we were like we were
stuck for like 20 minutes but then the
next one none of us made it through so I
didn't feel as bad that he is definitely
better than than at video games than me
but not that good all let's try W one it
had the same list of servers so I don't
know what that's going to change let's
see
here it's happened a lot by the way when
I was trying to grab footage of the new
models so what do you think about the
the level 90 leveling thing where you
can basically you know you're going to
get a level 90 character who with you
when you buy the game but you can also
just purchase one at any time the game
is well okay you get a free 90 first mhm
if you buy World Jer after that you can
buy new 90s and I think that's
completely fine like
I you you experienced how excruciating
leveling used to be right it has got a
lot better yeah true but I would easily
I would definitely pay just to bypass
that whole process you know cuz once
you've been through it the first time
around do you really need to go through
it again the game has so many expansion
packs that you're going to want to buy a
new character eventually just because
the leveling process is way too long
going through vanilla wow and then
burning Crusade and then wrath and then
see cataclysm and then miss pandia and
then now Warlords of dror that's just
way too much well but I think a lot of
people's concern comes from someone
who's never played the game at all and
just going to basically jump in at level
90 like is that is that a concern like
is that something you think people
should be worried about or like no not
at all is there so few people that it
that won't matter or no I think it's
fine it's it's also a way of getting
people that have never played the game
that just jump straight in that's
completely fine you know uh they'll
they'll Quest they'll get to 100 but
once you're 100 you know you're going to
have to learn to either raid or
PVP or you know one of the end games now
you have Garrison which I think are
going to be you know uh one of the I
don't know it's supposed to be a pretty
important gameplay mechanic you know uh
it's it's one of the newest things that
they're adding that's actually going to
be relevant to endgame I think I don't
know someone to cheat and chime in
like both of us are are pretty out of
the loop going to get more of the loop
like I I am excited for this game and I
have my
pre-order great why don't you look up
MMO Champion and and see how long this
is going to
last see what people are
saying see in the chat
now Garrison's equal mandatory you get a
level boost yeah 90 for one character
can jump into the game yeah you can jump
into the game at level 90 people are
asking for a clarification on that see
if MMO Champion that's how long the
servers are
down recent blue
post hold on go
up to the screen over here
see this is this is just beta stuff man
this just happens all the time it's a
normal
thing we'll hear word from our
production about what we're going to do
maybe I'll just sit here and talk about
W remin about
wow so how I I have I am a weird player
in in World of Warcraft and that i' I've
always played single player and like
groups were always pickup groups for me
and I felt bad for the people that were
forced to play with me because that
would just be me learning what to do and
just being in the group yeah that's
that's sort of a barrier of entry for
people that are new to the game because
you have to get over that whole anxiety
of like pissing people off MH and and
people won't hold back yeah so I just
didn't do it I just I've played solo
basically in the entire game and I have
I've rolled a couple characters I have
my druid and a hunter and a paladin and
those are my three favorite yeah but for
for someone like you who is probably
much more in line with the 7 million
like probably six to 5 to six million
other people who play it and are more
hardcore about it m i I guess what would
have been your your favorite things what
have been your favorite moments I guess
just some of the more hardcore aspects
of the game were pretty nice um when me
and Eric Eric Tay we used to actually
compete in PvP in the arena and they
would give you specific rewards for
placing really high in your ranking they
would give you titles Like Gladiator in
dualist and I think we were dualist
which was top 3% of your server yeah top
3% I'm proud of
that uh rating I didn't care too much
for until it became more casual if you
remember wrath blitch gang yeah they
started giving you Buffs to make the
game like to make the whole dungeon
easier and that was a really nice raid
though um what was it
called the one where you fight
arthus I'm not good with the names yeah
whatever I really like the achievements
and adding those in because that gave me
something to do to chase after the
holiday like chasing after holiday
achievements and just kind of silly
things like
that oh I used to like Hollow and it a
lot I don't know why you know the one
where they used to give you the costumes
and stuff that you can turn into you can
still throw pumpkins at people make them
wear pumpkins on their head jam it on
their
head uh somebody oh somebody said does
guy and red work for blizzard no no I I
work here at Game
Spot you might not see me a lot because
I work in the dungeons writing
news but uh I have no affiliation with
blizzard I do like their games but I'm
very bad at them I still don't have a
level 90 character how long is the
server outage Ty huh Ser we're just
sitting here talking oh my god there are
people showing up oh he's going down
into the basement below us it looks just
like the original wow you can't get in
terorist don't work and you didn't pay
them this this menu is new we didn't
have this back in the day the client
yeah the client's nice this looks like
this is great yeah this is more like
original W I should just load Diablo
right now play
Diablo so Mary what's on the
lobby um we consider this oh really if
this
happens um I don't think we're going to
play it this happen it's would be good
good for the lobby we though this
specifically yeah beta where we just
look at the menu I I missed this login
screen this is the first one or is it
yeah I think it is MHM you have the gate
there's the fires what's
your right now A Toren but it's usually
a blood elf girl
yeah of course the best the best race do
you usually
cross oh yeah myself this
giant on what on what I think I also was
an
elf everyone was an elf everyone is an
elf Legolas to me it was what I could
associate not the actual human yeah no
those you needed the pointy ears
got somebody asks Mary username is Mary
Gish question mark Gish that would be
great very cash oh my gosh I haven't
played vanilla in a really long
time look at that 1100
people try to log in diggers
333 grave diggers 33 says maybe 30
minutes before we can get back in this
is awful see now that we brought in Mary
and it's just us like full here on the
screen we bringing in more people and we
just spam advertisements during this
thing can we play some music yeah can
you guys just watch advertis Japanese
keep us
employed I I think half an hour Mary
maybe 30 minutes that's fine right guys
everyone just wants to watch us
wait oh my email on the SC oh yeah I
don't use this email anymore so don't
bother
spaming connected yeah okay thank God
you're
oh my God we can
play they're in I bet it
crashes what music stops he's trying to
right when you said
that all right I'm let you do your thing
all right thanks Mar you six
it very Kish everybody video things
work you see the special
effects how
fancy Shadow all right so
got to destroy these devices which are
located in various
places have you tried any of the other
you know more recent MMOs that I I guess
have more action behind them is that
something that I played wild star for a
stress test and
what oh okay look I'm killing it and I
got an error that's what seees Break
Stuff thanks a lot Eric you're still
helpful I'm just kidding please help
me um but no yeah I played I played
WildStar and it's just so hard oh Guild
Wars 2 as well it's just so hard to play
MMOs for me these days and uh I don't
know if
it's because I was a wild player for so
long that I so tired of the monotonous
quests of like picking up flowers and
mhm yeah but at the same time this is
something that hasn't changed that much
I mean it is even though it's it's
looking better and it feels I feel like
World of Warcraft is really streamlined
it's still you know click kill stuff yep
and all this questing is really just a
means to get to the end end
game but it's cool though cuz everyone's
out in the world
and do you think there's more
fuzzy we'll meet again fuzzy
wuzzy do you think there's more of a
pull for for people that never got into
something like wow for for something
that is a more you know action oriented
game where you're doing stuff or do you
think there's still something behind the
Simplicity of something like World of
Warcraft I don't know what motivation
for anyone that hasn't already played
wow pick it up everything everything in
this game pretty much caters to all the
people that play or have played I
think oh look new
ax oh by the way yes that is something
we should talk about um I did notice
when I was looking at my inventory this
is template character by the way yeah
this is just the character that you get
thrown into look look how much strength
is on these gloves for level 90 37
strength 37 that's even lower than you
know vanilla right yeah so they scaled
everything down because the numbers were
getting too crazy like people were
critting and hitting for like a million
damage and stuff uh I don't know how
hard I've been hitting for cuz I think I
have that turned off but yeah uh not
only that but I
mean now you see that grade out
statistic the intellect so basically now
they don't have to have multiple
versions of uh the same kind of item or
you know as a reward uh basically it'll
just uh detect your primary stat and
it'll activate that so this will be good
whether you're a warrior or Paladin so
yeah there's
that thought that was interesting oh
that's really
cool where do I go now back there maybe
we can finally get out of here soon look
there's no seems like shut it down bad
way to go
to this is right I think I have to go
under oh okay no I do have
to what
path it's either a part of it or it's
underneath it it could be like right
along the outside I'm just going to take
the way that I took before and let's see
if it teleports me
this has worked for us over and over
again I know Justin hates me for doing
this constantly I love this area Justin
I love getting
stuck yeah so Z so they're resetting
back to
vanilla which not not
quite yeah why why would in terms of
stats I I guess oh I see yeah yeah
almost it it's just just reset and it
should last them another decade now I
guess what exactly is this giving me I
already have these abilities have a new
Mission stay alive that's awesome compl
sure get the thing
legs destroy eight bleeding Hollow Huts
all righty anything you say
buddy that area so now we get to leave
this is pretty normal I I don't know if
you played when they had this but now
you don't have to search your inventory
to use the quest item you could just
yeah that such a nice
addition cuz I I did get a little bit
tired of keeping track of mods M and
then when they just finally put that as
part of the game as it would just makes
sense it felt like not keeping stuff
like that was more of a hindrance than
anything like there's no reason not to
to put in things that just make
usability so much easier
M and I I'm glad that they kind of wisen
up to that they didn't feel
like they they're making the experience
they want to make and that all this
other stuff is too much of a help yeah I
love how they kind of tell you which
which guys to kill just by having the
little red font how many more of each
one of those you need to kill and and
that's something that a lot of other
MMOs have borrowed now because it is so
handy being able to Mouse over and see
like this is someone that this is the
next thing you need to go after or I
this so have you been playing wildar or
anything I actually don't know how it's
doing is it doing well it seems like
it's it's doing pretty okay it's hard to
tell you know when a when an MMO first
comes out because it is going to be
really busy like they you have so many
people who are just jumping on who are
going to try out for a month yeah and
because that comes packaged in when you
buy the game so how much how long those
legs are going to last is is harder to
tell cuz I've spent some time in wildar
and sometime in Elder Scrolls Online mhm
and I I mean I still prefer the World of
Warcraft experience yeah okay yeah so do
I Elder Scrolls just feels too much like
Elder Scrolls it doesn't feel like an
MMO it feels like here's a new Elder
Scrolls game but not quite as
deep like in I I didn't I didn't feel
like it was a real MMO it doesn't feel
that different is it because there
aren't people like that you can see out
there in the world no there are lots of
people you can see but I never felt the
need to get toam up with anybody yeah
like all the quests even just kind of
going straight along it didn't really
introduce me to things that that needed
more
people and wild star is fun like I do
like the the cartoony aspect of the
graphics which I think fit something
like this so much better but the oh burn
the Huts I heard oh yeah yeah ladder
wasn't paying attention oh that was
easy yeah
burn sure I pressed the button that's
awesome press the button too
what are people saying in the chat
saying oh my God you're so terrible why
are you playing like
th someone says what's the guy's name in
the M coat yeah Justin that's me he
works for blizzard I do I work for
blizzard I'm a I'm a blizzard employee
who knows everything about the blizzard
games I'm very good at them and PaRappa
the
Rapper
uh
yeah and some people are kind of
reiterating what I was saying that wild
star is doing well in terms of
subscribers but it it feels a little too
much like wow it is more action focused
in terms of the combat a lot of people
on that team are from the the old wow
team right but I don't feel like I'm
getting that much different than wow and
I just prefer how how well all of this
is done I don't want to learn more new
lore like that's that's already a hard
pull for me yeah so it's like the fact
that wow has brought me in as much as it
has and I and I would not say that I
know a lot about the lore of the the
worlds that they they've already crossed
a barrier for me to learn a video game
lore and things that are going on Wild
Star is like that's a hurdle you have to
get me over if you if you if you're
going to try to make me learn about your
fictional history of something so huge
and like just tendrils and everything I
I almost want to say that's the biggest
that's the hardest hurdle for anyone
making an MMO is just getting people in
the lore and interested in it work yeah
like who who cares about some of these
things yeah you have to have it big
enough to to have a real world with
people starting in different parts of it
in all different races mhm but then how
do you make each individual story so
compelling that you care about these new
things you've created yeah especially
when you have to read these quests and
you don't have someone just voicing it
to you
mhm what about like shooter type MMOs
Destiny is is more of an MMO than a
shooter I didn't I didn't get to play
that at all how was that it's a it's a
shooter it's a shooter in which you see
a few other people so I I got to the
point where the the meme started where
uh you have Peter Dinklage say that
wizard came from the Moon and that was
as far as I made it I was like oh this
is too ridiculous for me to keep playing
and then after that weekend I like that
became a meme to itself where that is
what everybody was talking about it's
fun
enough do you think it'll succeed
that's hard to tell the hype the hype is
probably the hype is to much to live up
to
yeah without that hype that's you need
those people playing it and who are
excited to get into it and who are going
to be the evangelists telling their
friends about it and that's what that we
do we find games that we're excited
about and and hope that you know the
audience latches on in the same way
because we want people to play with us
your blades never I do that that's not
true I don't want I I play so I play all
these games solo I'm such a liar I play
World of Warcraft all by myself I don't
like meeting other people why the only
other people I meet are the people that
I kill in server or I just I join a pug
I join a pickup group just to make
people unhappy with their lives and
really mad at me yeah I would be one of
those guys yelling at you I'm sorry no
no like like the first time that I
signed up like I didn't do any group
rating until like really late in the
game like I just played completely solo
I didn't have friends who were playing
with me and and I signed up for one of
the it it was when they introduced The
Raid Helper and I was like oh I'll be
the tank I'm a tank class I do that and
so I I jump into the The Raid and
they're like hey hey tank like go pull
that mob I'm like how do I do that like
throw your Shield like I didn't spec
that like why don't you have the shield
throwing thing like oh I didn't know
that would be a good thing to have I
thought I would just be the tank you
know they'll hit me I love how it's
supposed to be a given that you're
supposed to know all of it there's so
much responsibility at being a tank and
they've they've tried to make it easier
I it didn't help that like and I learned
after that like oh I should have just
been PS and that might not might not
have made people as mad at me but it
made it a lot more fun for me yeah no
but even then you know they have uh
damage meters and they'll track and see
that you're not doing very much damage
and they'll yell at you so either way
then after that I just ran around and
got like kited a whole bunch of mobs
like hey guys take care of
it oh and then they all died what an
a-hole I like it though all right what
are these orbs that didn't that that
group didn't last
long so you said you're your one of your
normal characters is a dark elf night
Elf blood elf blood elf what are the
regular elves called High Elves High
Elves they got turned into blood elves
do you tend to do cross gaming do you
tend to to play as a female character in
these kind of games cross gaming is that
really what they call it I don't know
that's what I call it like crossdressing
cross
gaming yeah I played a female blood elf
and you know people people wonder why
you're playing a female I just it's
better to look at right yeah you don't I
don't act like a girl when I'm playing
it I don't have like yeah people give
you gifts though yeah yeah they do which
is kind of creepy like your may or may
not roll with it you know it's hard to
say often you just have to hit SL dance
and like people just like wow this is
weird you you don't know what I look
like on the other side of this oh what
is this
now I think that's
kill forgot the
yep warlord of the bleeding Hollow love
this voice over yeah look what dragging
itself through my jungle fresh
meat Rock sounds like such a dork and
the eye of saon is watching
you okay going this
way what did you get out of that little
cinematic
there I am killr we learned to kill Rog
dead ey yeah I learned to kill Rock dead
ey you remember uh Warcraft 2 I of Kill
Rock do you remember that spell did you
play that game I did not play world
Warcraft 2 back in oh Warcraft one no
did you start three I started at three
oh okay I played a little bit of one but
I don't I barely even remember it now I
love how I'm learning all these skills
that I already
have what is the point of
that oh I wonder if that's a little
placeholder for people that
are that are making their their new 99s
I guess when you get a free 90 you're
not going to get all your skills at once
it's going to be kind of like the death
knight leveling experience where you
quest and you get skills eventually and
that's how they teach you how to
play yeah cuz overall this is not quite
as exciting as some of the intros
what this is awesome the world looks a
lot
better I I really loved when introduced
the Goblins as a character I thought
that that intro world was just a lot of
fun oh uh with the goblin world yeah oh
wow did you ever make a death knight I
actually like that I did make a death
knight
ah that was killing innocent people
interesting to get to play from that
that side
yeah be evil they make you question
whether what you're doing is right or
not but you still have to do it yeah you
got to do it though you I mean you are a
th for the the leech King Le King people
might notice how many empty keybinds I
have by the way they took away a lot of
skills where's my heroic
strike sure I feel the Flames press the
button no one cares press the button oh
they're they're watching see they they
care
stop please
all
right you think do you think there's
room for for bringing a game back like
Warcraft like the original Warcraft not
the MMO version of this cuz STC Oh you
mean as an RTS yeah yeah eventually I I
think that once they sort of settle this
new storyline that they introduced with
all with gash and everything yeah
that'll that'll make way for that oh by
the way they have a movie coming out
right oh they do yeah
so I think a good time would be after
that movie to bring back the the RTS
version yeah cuz then people buy it yeah
and then you can make wow too right
after that just keep getting the
money but what would what would a wow to
be like it feels like you're just we're
going to keep getting these kind of
expansions and this is this experience
they would have to change the engine
right this is the same engine
essentially
that that we've played ever since what
2004 or so they just skinned it all to
look
nicer so yeah they would have to redo
everything from scratch basically
and that might be too much work for them
to really but wouldn't that split the
user base like especially if you're
calling it World of Warcraft 2 whoa
that and and you know that might be why
they had that that project Titan instead
so that has gone back to the drawing
board yeah
unfortunately it's probably going to be
like
Destiny like I don't feel like to to me
that they would ever want to split they
would ever want to take away unless this
just bottomed out of if there became one
one and a half or 2 million subscribers
then maybe they wouldn't care but 7
million concurrent subscribers is still
more than most other games any other
paid game certainly there are some other
free play any other do well probably
more players than than these fre MMOs
not all of there are some free MMOs that
have ridiculous numbers they like the
Korean on yeah oh yeah I bet argument
there you can start multiple accounts
like the numbers are maybe a little
fuzzy but they're they're also free this
is 7 million people pay monthly to play
this and and you know if they make just
another MMO IP that's going to be set
they're just going to double up
basically anyone that's still playing
wow is probably going to play the new
MMO so but a lot of people were wanting
to get into Wild Star because of its
more Spacey thing and that's what some
people like about it that it is
basically World of Warcraft but parts of
it in space and the animations look kind
of nice kind of like a uh like a dream
Works film or Pixar film mhm people
might get angry for me saying that oh
yeah Ricky guitarist mentions they just
finished shooting the Wild movie they
yeah they're going into postprocessing
now for like the next two years oh wow
is it really going to take that long
it's not coming out
until what year are we now oh no one
year year and a half it's going to be
what cuz it's April 20 no 26 2015 April
2015 yeah that's a release dat yes oh
okay that's not bad we might get a
trailer soon there maybe a Comic Con
because Star Wars is this Christmas
right is it yes cuz origal well
originally their the release date was
around Christmas and then Star Wars had
their release date which was also around
Christmas and blizzard being intelligent
about this went let's move our movie to
another date which is not the Star Wars
date yep very smart but then Harrison
Ford broke his ankle and they're still
filming so might push Star
Wars in game cutcenes
yes someone's been following all this
and can summarize it to me later because
I have not been paying
attention lar friend what is it you wish
kill 10
dudes kill specific 2015 what year is oh
so it's not this Christmas oh yes yeah
so this course yeah 2015 must be right
so it'll be December 2015 and then after
so we still have over a year and a half
man that's so long my hopes up man cuz
we don't even have a trailer for that
so I mean part of it postprocessing but
I just the fact that they moved it to
make sure it's not in in the Star Wars
time frame part of it is also like
timing for the movie like there's got to
be a point in which they'll finish it
and then just be like now we want to
wait for for the right time cuz movies
have the have the power to do that
whereas video games tend to not like
they want to I I've never heard of
someone like Rel I don't want to say I
have heard of that yeah I think so but
not for that not for months and like
sometimes Studios have sat on a movie
for over a year before they actually put
it out there whereas a game you don't
tend to do that a game you tend to want
to be a bit quicker yeah but I sometimes
I've heard of game studi sitting on a
game for a couple months after it's
finished
or versions of a game at least like
Watch Dogs it's reported that the Wii U
version of that is basically done they
could put it out at any time they just
don't feel like they're going to make a
return there's not going to be enough of
a return on it yeah I think it'd be nice
if these uh ging development companies
took their time the way blizzard does
cuz blizzard really Prides itself on its
quality although we had this discussion
before lately it seems almost like
expected that Blizzard's going to
release something new every year right
yeah that's they've been talking about
from here on there's basically going to
be a new expansion every one to to two
years at the least but they going to be
regular expansions it's not just going
to be this huge event that it is now
that it's going to be regular updates to
the story and
four is that a good thing or is that
something that is you feel like is too
much is what a good thing
is what if they did update this every
year if there's just basically a new
expansion every year I I mean I I think
that's fine um unless you hate the
current games then that's not okay like
a lot of people are not happy with
Diablo I but they're just going to keep
updating that right I'm happy with
Diablo I but what do I do here what are
you telling me to do here oh one some
dudes that are no longer
there just click on the thing no I can't
click on it oh
H what do I have see just figure it out
do you play any of the other blizzard
IPS Starcraft I don't play Starcraft but
I I do play some uh Diablo play a lot of
hearthstone Hearthstone is more my speed
because I can play it on iPad and I I
like how casual hearstone is I I don't
mean that as an insult I I like that you
can just play and browse Reddit on the
side that's that's pretty awesome and
it's Steve there's a there's a lot to it
once you once you start ranking up oh
yeah mhm it's not I mean it's easy to
get into and easy to get through the you
the introduction and the first few ranks
but it's a very deep game for such a a
small oneoff something that they could
have just thrown out as absolutely
nothing yeah no they they definitely
took their time on that I think they're
releasing a new card mhm there's going
to be a single player expansion to that
I think B uh curse of NEX Ramis so also
time more into the lore for people that
really love World of Warcraft you get
the Hearthstone stuff takes expand on
that even more whoa
shortcuts
not I know Eric there is loving watching
me grind right
now I know that sounds kind of dirty too
oh God legion's end do not think of it
that
wayos all right Tay was uh regaling the
chat with Tales of his history oh yeah I
was a raid leader back then and uh I
played Hunter
wrath void next year I'm calling it now
he was a raid leader he did rally 40
people
together for molten core oh my god did
you ever do molten core I did not do
molten core I I'm such a I'm in the
worst use of the word I'm a very casual
player of most
games but uh do you do you kind of have
the gist of of what it was the raid back
then it was like if you have someone
that's out of position one out of 40
people obviously you're going to have at
at least one right uh yeah everyone dies
and then you got to do it
again I had a friend my roommate I got
hucked on Wow and he would be really
into it and I wouldn't play like I just
didn't have time to devote as much as he
did so I would watch him raid and and
I'll watch YouTube videos but the amount
of time spent you know being in this 40
Man dungeon and learning your place and
and moving around was yeah you have to
study before before you you attempted a
raid that's a lot of work and I it's
like I'm just going to go around and do
some Mining and collect some
flowers stop doing that
please come
on ER T says 40 Man raids stole one to
two years of my life I think we weren't
even a good build generous too one to
two years I think it's more than that
Eric it's more than that back then I
never quit for longer than a month
uh thumb skill says add worst thing ever
was a ragnaros 1% wipe oh
yeah see see I'm with
uh goo Sher I don't know how to say that
go I don't know how you can have a job
and still play wow it requires so much
time it's true because I one of the the
other reason I didn't want to say that
is because my roommate at the time was
unemployed he kind of worked from home
uh selling airsoft guns um and he work
from home well it worked from home which
eventually became I play World of
Warcraft
fulltime and that did he sell anything
in the game no by chance no okay he just
no no he was like that was just his life
yeah he just became I wake up in the
morning and I play World of Warcraft and
then my roommate comes home and I'm
still here playing and I say hi to him I
have a pile of some Chinese takeout that
I have
eaten and that's all I felt really bad
because that was definitely a downward
spiral it is I may or may not have been
in that same spiral who knows what is it
you wish maybe it's just a
coincidence that I didn't graduate while
I was playing wow see I always I always
want to get back into it and be really
dedicated but I'm I just have so many
other things pulling me in different
directions you would you would basically
have to finish work go home and start
playing right away and ignore your
girlfriend
oh unless she played then you were one
to look and then it's socializing yeah
oh that's basically that's kind of what
we did with wow when even when nothing
was going on since your friends played
you could at least use it as kind of
like a messenger service while you just
jumped around town doing this and typing
to other people by the way I should have
been hiding this the entire time luckily
no one's written anything bad in chat
people are talking it's a lot of a lot
of Eric T A lot of people are talking
about some the talking about the chat
here oh that CH yeah I never paid
attention to that I ignore that
completely do you play more PVP or PVE
um I'm mostly all PVP uh cuz that's a
little easier to be able to just jump in
and que for for
Battleground and uh have that
satisfaction of beating other people
AB yeah whereas if you raided he would
have to you know do all this stuff to
prepare for your raid you would have to
farm all your goodies made sure all your
gear was up to up to
par the one person was asking about
Titan that was the supposedly cancelled
um lizzard MMO mhm that we don't know
anything about and was never officially
uh and never officially announced that
totally wasn't a first person MMO
totally wasn't a Starcraft like
environment there's a lot of things that
definitely
wasn't I think we just all had that idea
I wonder if it was really anything close
to that at all yeah it could have been
absolutely nothing or could have been
World of Warcraft 2 Eric will agree with
me if if they made a you know a game an
MMO that was basically like World of
Starcraft we would all play so many
people would play that universe is just
like too cool not to want to be a part
of Eric T says space of Starcraft space
of yeah okay Universe Universe of
Starcraft why why would that be would do
you think you would never play with
again to play that
instead that depends how similar they
are see that's that's where uh that
first person aspect might you know
really be bre effective cuz then if it's
different enough then you would probably
play both maybe you play this first
person you just zoom in all the way like
look all right sure first person wow oh
it's a new mod new mode this is so weird
totally official his his tree logs are
blocking my entire view where's the
other guy
oh he's
dead oh my God these are so many weapons
to collect I'm sure I can actually click
on some of these and get some blizzard
likely spent lots and lots of money on
Titan but when you're a game when you're
a company that is making so much money
like you can do that you want to invest
money in and trying to figure out new
ways to do things which is Hearthstone
was a gamble that was very relatively
very little money that's paying off
hugely yeah I think they're they're
starting to figure out how to how to
make a lot of money off of these
microtransactions just like just like
any gun G company is yeah well you mean
you can buy so many different mounts and
little pets oh did you get into to the
pet stuff uh in this game yeah in World
of Warcraft no I did not uh that's a
whole meta game unto itself oh okay yeah
that's right you have Pokemon in this
game right yeah you have this is Pokemon
this is the Pokemon MMO people wanted I
wonder how many people do that probably
a lot enough for them to make
money people buy pets for that yeah like
with real money you can buy pets with
real
money uh I remember back then when they
first introduced microtransactions uh I
think they had this really cool mount it
was basically like a spectral unicorn
kind of thing all that kind of told me
when I saw it when I saw other people
with it I didn't think like oh my God
that mount's so cool I just basically
thought oh my God you paid $25 for that
some are nice some are charity based
though it's like donating money to
charity way they make me feel bad some
most of them are just waste of money
though like you can point out like you
are someone who has too much money
yeah that's true though no there's
nothing wrong with the charity
wins no you should those people should
feel bad too
like you could have given that money
directly to the charity just saying it's
too far away I'm out of R oh Ricky
guitar says Eric are they still working
on the Titan reboot or is it just
completely dead Titan does not
exist if Titan were in production then
it is still in production but it is not
official oh that one shouldn't be inir
quots it's not
official we asked that like last bitcon
we we got to to talk with some of the
guys we're like so hey you know what's
up with Titan we got the the word that
it was cancelled and their their answer
was basically we've never announced
Titan oh it's so easy for them to just
you here that this is not a thing that
is actually uh an official thing we are
talking about please please keep this
talking about uh World of Warcraft and
the things that are on
message H how
boring that's a pretty that's some sweet
armor I would buy that oh yeah in the
game not won't tell you that though what
if they
did someone says I have excessive use of
air
quotes that's cuz he works for
bliard obviously
all okay I should start paying attention
to numb yeah 8,000
crits much lower than my Millions day
the sparkle
pony oh man there is so much grinding it
does it is I haven't done this in so
long
this is very grind like hopefully this
is more the intro 90 experience and
it'll be a little it'll be a little bit
better if you come into the world with
your own 90 and you know what actually
there is nothing wrong with this cuz I
remember now back in the day I would
just put a something on Netflix on the
other monitor and so I kind of thank wow
for me being able to complete the Lost
series cuz I was just put lost on mute
this and yeah just click click on things
LEL the
audio so one even though I do play
pretty casually one thing I never got
into is fishing and I never understood
the appeal of people who would also just
put on audio like I'm just going to go
fishing yeah did you ever level up your
skills like were you fish or there well
okay no not not just a fish like if
there was something worth fishing like
uh that thing that that fish that turns
you into a ninja yeah basically I I did
fishing just to be able to get that
that's about it and you could sell those
too for a lot of gold whatever back in
the day so yeah that was the only reason
why I did that I didn't understand that
either but
I think people actually had Bots for
that cuz you could you could set
something to right click for you and it
would yeah I I guess I never really got
the that the importance of fishing but I
I still level up my cooking they made an
importantance later so you could yeah so
you could food for your
raid one of the
Reas yeah some people say I find fishing
to be relaxing
just right
clicking like real just like real
fishing I guess do you like fishing in
real life yeah relaxing yeah okay need
to sit at the water it's a chance to
drink beer and talk or not talk and look
at the
water Dan says that's why I play games
to virtually
fish why I play games talk to girls
online or to
get online identity says to get out of a
raid I or get out of raid just want to
veg out for a bit but still play wow so
you go sit and
fish
a yeah if I didn't fish all I did was
jump around in the city anyways my
friends joke around that that's that's
one of our favorite things to do is just
jump around yeah our space bars would
get worn out because of that I don't
know what it is about jumping it's so
nice people don't do that in Wild Star
as much so I would that's I don't know
why that is such a wild thing oh really
so I just go wildar and I'm just like
jumping around on everybody nice show
them what's up show them how to play in
MMO hey hey how's it hey how's it going
you doing it all wrong why are you
standing in
place could you get any rares or epics
from fishing I did not epic
fish did someone yell TR in the
quest not I'm getting there right these
guys keep running into
me I I kind of just want to kill more of
these guys just a just a piss air off
yeah look at these crits
14k all right Eric what's in store for
the next
quest one of the other Warlords is going
to introduce himself and say I am so and
so and then I'm going to have to kill 10
more guys I am
bullog going to break the
D who those water
effects very sound to be added
later oh now it's flooded I don't know
why he did that if only I read the story
oh you know he he wanted a good fishing
spot Dre thar this is th's
Dad the also the guy you kill if you're
Alliance at the end of alter Valley you
know that a I did not know that you
didn't did you do that Battleground I
didn't know it was it's like
a I've went to alter Valley it was very
boring was so fun very
big this is now playing director's cut
according to Ricky
guitarist alter Valley was the worst
Battleground according to Ricky took
forever no that's that's why it was so
good you just kill people constantly and
then you would summon those guys to help
you the ice Lord your
horde or The Druids if you're an
ally so the game looks better I I I do
enjoy the look of the world but at the
same time it feels like I mean it's a
little more jungly but it doesn't feel
like a different place like I remember
this area yeah what is this area
supposed to be even like I don't even
know this cuz you know this is outlands
right it's like yeah prehistoric became
outlands it's very kind of prehistoric
kind I don't know what area this is oh
this is supposed to be Hellfire
Peninsula because the Portal's here you
remember the in in burning Crusade the
first area that you enter that's all red
yeah this is what this area is oh okay
yeah yeah I guess
that's thing sure why
not 45 Talent a lot great
what was
that it's the ball give Eternal
stench okay I hope that's in the
game by the way I'm pretending that was
in game but it was really just Justin
yeah sorry oh Eric T made the same joke
all right nice this is why me and him
are
friends here they don't have sound
effects in while cut scenes or do they
this is the the beta yeah it'll be in
there later yeah I think you know you
never know the game's not coming up for
there probably won't be any vocals we
don't have a date on this yet do we um
no but you know they T yeah late fall
more more likely than
not I would I would say Thanksgiving
later yeah it Eric Tay says it's Q4 this
year whatever that means fall
fallish
so who's watching this and saying oh my
God I gotta
play so some people were asking if they
could donate to Gamespot and Dan said uh
we take donations in the form of weird
hot sauces to torture Eric with you just
send beer we don't take actual uh
donations not a charity playing video
games you can donate beer but Dan not
money oh the torture chamber
there is no return of torture chamber
Eric my name's
Eric did you watch torture chamber back
in the day no oh how dare you yeah I'm a
bad game
spotter that was Eric's show I'll have
to go back and see some back episodes
Let's uh give it a hashtag hash
bringback torture
chamber oh sub button yeah so oh do we
have a sub button no I I don't know
wonder I don't know I don't know how
twitch works
I you're not hip I'm not hip with the
kids and they're cool lingo what you
need be
safe yeah I mean now that you
mention you know the connection to uh to
the burning Crusade world
and I it's kind of interesting but it's
still I I guess I would have wanted
something that's visually little bit
more appealing like different yeah it it
just feels like a lot of places I've
already been uh yeah yeah that's true um
I I think this was just their attempt to
bring it I I guess cuz there were so
many
interesting uh lore figures in the past
that they they wanted to make the wild
world a part of that cuz you know some
of these new characters like I really
don't care too much about like garage
like whatever mhm kind even as a hord
guy yeah yeah well cuz he was such a
douche you know and
and they they kind of made you question
whether you liked him or not but no
everyone hated
him go here to get to
there see yeah Z is saying they normally
do a live raate at BlizzCon and if they
didn't have it out with plenty of time
for the top Raiders to progress they
couldn't have one or they'd have to do
Siege of ogore two years in a row yeah
it's it's pretty that we'll see this
before Bliss gon I really actually
wanted to do that raid Siege of or but I
never did because was just so out of
wow cuz that sounds pretty cool right
raiding someone's you know faction City
what am I doing
here powder
K World breaker
schematics I think they have all the Mr
panderia beta raids pre-release of uh
mop it was just not all the
bosses look at that yeah evil mle 12 is
with me this place looks incredibly
boring and dull nothing really pops out
see you really have to already be an
existing Wild player to appreciate it
that's what it feels like so far like I
know I'm like I'm going to play this and
I I want to explore the world but I feel
like if I was if I was just coming in
for the first time this would not be I
wouldn't watch someone play this and go
oh yeah man I've been missing out on
World of Warcraft all these years I
watch it and go yeah I can't wait to get
back in and play
this what is the point of destroying
that I'm trying to figure this Quest out
hold on but uh yeah like like like I
told you I think before stream I thought
bring Crusade was the best expansion mhm
as far as introducing new players uh
well no not necessarily no just just in
terms of overall like balance between
the difficulty and and having the
hardcore aspects of the game so a lot of
people have Nostalgia for that area so
basically you know they're bringing us
back to where we liked right and just
reskinning it and calling it a new game
so some people are asking is the beta
out now this is the the beta that's
currently out there and if we are not
giving out beta keys right now which we
might be somewhere on the site uh you'll
be able to find some yeah we have keys
to give out we do have keys to give out
they might they should be live now if
they're not live now they're going to be
live tomorrow but they're going to be
very limited the lobbying the lobby
maybe possibly they might give you some
hints about where to find them if it's
not totally clear yet we'll find a way
to give it to you yes you will be able
to get into this beta and make fun of us
right there make fun of me because I'm
terrible at all games including wow
let's just make Danny play wow I'm sure
he plays a lot yeah he no he has for a a
key we gave him one as well oh
yeah oh am I that's going to be awesome
can I just PVP during the stream yes uh
it'll be kind of like this like there's
a yellow dot here which signifies what
why are live chores more entertaining
than pre-recorded ones a sorry I
shouldn't because of chat interactions
yeah that helps because otherwi because
otherwise it's dead air and it would
just be us talking this gives me a
chance to look away from having to make
things up with my brain and read answers
and questions and you got to see me
stuck on that second quest for like 15
minutes and then servers went down yeah
but when we're stuck on things that
gives us more interaction time when it's
a recorded show you don't have that
element of I have to make something up
right
now okay de press the makeshift plunger
where's this
plunger oh Dan says follow us here on
Twitch and you'll get notified when we
go live with
keys slame Shameless
plug oh
Dan hey Eric where the hell do I
go yeah there was a lot lot more Eric T
mentions this as well there was more
handholding in C
cataclysm CSM was the was the one where
they they brought heroics back to their
harder difficulty and that's where a lot
of the people started to leave wow
actually so that was trying to make the
game harder right
so looking for raid was introduced later
on in kater yeah that was not looking
for me was not there at the outset yeah
uh oh you you're leaving a trail of
black powder yeah I am probably
supposed there there's a reason for this
probably but I am kind of lost I don't
know can you set it on fire you have to
make it to a fire oh right like there's
fire there are flaming swords there's
fire over there you touch a fire only if
only this game where is literal see if I
were to do
this you have to jump in it oh oh that
didn't
hurt what are you supposed to do
depress the makeshift plunger I don't
want to read you have to depress the
makeshift plunger find a keg and then
return it to hanzel oh where's hanzel oh
okay this is where we do SL Target
hanzel and he's not in the area hold
on why this guy that's yellow
huh oh man it is oh imminent stranger
says do you need to be a wild player to
beta or can noobs check it out I I
believe you'll have to have a WOW
account to try out the beta for you
today right no you don't you don't you
can yeah but but they I think they
admitted that they mostly just gave keys
to veteran Wild players I don't know how
they determined that probably people
that sub the
longest yep Eric says he got into this
beta without having miss the Pandaria no
he had have Miss the Pand
yeah t says you need Mr Pandaria so you
would have to okay all
right well D Dexter jock says this isn't
even a game yet it's a beta talking
about how reviews are paid for because
we've done nothing but glowing with
praise I want to play it like because
I'm a wow person and that I'm a casual
wow person yeah you're still a wild
player most people are casual but it's
not this isn't something I feel like is
very new it's not groundbreaking that's
for sure but you know they've been stuck
in M of panderia for so long a hedg v
says this will be the first WoW
expansion I don't buy kind of sad
feeling but me life goes on just buy it
you know you're going to do it anyways
don't BS
me I don't know I've though because I
quit after so long not ready I'm still
going to play this though so but
probably for like a month I guess I was
a little more excited before seeing it
oh really by the possibilities and I
still want to see what the Garrison are
like
but okay so where's this makeshift
plunger uh oh it's not okay there we
go big powder KI on your back that seems
safe look how much how many trails I
made want to see it all explode yeah or
at least catch on fire got it
you're big Toren it's hard to
see sweet that's all I needed to do look
off with you all right it captured
everywhere that I
walked no no didn't all light a little
bit in the background um where's the
next
Quest why
gunpowder some people mention that they
like the new player models and may race
change how much longer are we going
Eric 9 minutes so until 5 I want to find
some Alliance I don't think this laptop
is going to last me that long I'm going
to look for some Alliance let's try
to go look
around open your heart to the
light it's a very toasty laptop that I
put on me it's very
hot cuz it's so intensive right now just
streaming and yeah all the all the so
much going on I know people really
wanted to know that
temperature of my loins very high right
now because of this it usually is high
anyways hotter than normal sweaty humid
kind of like this jungle environment
that we're walking around in you just
imagine the humidity coming off of the
laptop this we get the
point oh man I realized it wasn't clear
from the the image of just seeing my
head going be in
there I'm not going to find any Alliance
Christopher Robins says GameStop
Gamespot never streams games ever at all
we never stream games never no I guess
some people had not seen us streaming
games before somehow but you should
probably follow us on uh on Twitch come
to the site you know our our our
streaming schedule is up on on
gamespot.com so you can check that out
we have plenty of quality
programming and if I weren't so lazy I
would probably list them all out let's
go someone asked what class I play you
would think or I would have assumed that
I would play a hunter since I do like to
play solo but I always felt like Hunter
took so much micromanaging of the pet
that I actually play P Paladin is my
solo class of choice I was Druid for a
while you didn't think P was boring I
thought pal was I really I actually
really like Paladin tanking with a
paladin is is kind of nice and I like
the ability to if I ever do decide to go
into groups that I can be a tank or a
Healer yeah I think healing was actually
pretty easy with the Paladin have you
have you tried being a Healer that's
possibility too yeah yeah I I didn't
feel like putting up or making anyone
put up with that that seemed like it
would be a little too mean you get all
of the blame and none of the praise a
blameless job I mean thankless yeah
we've done several game streams all day
today we did uh we did PaRappa the rappa
we were just doing kind of a weird indie
game on meab bit at uh on meab bit
multiple players 10 Pacific multi
players to
Pacific it's like it's like TV there's a
schedule where you can just go to
gamespot.com look at your bottom right
it's somewhere there pretty sure pretty
sure it's bottom right super hul lock
2222 says in my opinion healer is an
option if healer is an option you be
it healers are one of my favorite
classes in other games I do like healing
people where is this oh there he
is why didn't you illuminate him you
wanted me to talk to him watch back
watch
back I also like playing a gnome they're
short everyone loves gnomes like me I
feel like I can relate probably more
gnomes than
humans they removed zerker
stance yes I think unless you spec fury
it's not here oh actually I think they
call it Gladiator standing or some
I don't know not ready yet it Druids
yeah I used to like when when we used to
have to manage our stances for certain
skills but they had to make Warrior a
little easier I guess just to keep it in
line with all the other
classes here climb These
Chains it's been about a little less
than an hour I mean we did have the
server out we got to look at the
characters a little bit yeah no I think
it's been more
than yeah it's been a while it's been
like an hour and a half so I think we're
down for like maybe 20 minutes or 15
minutes I don't know so are you are you
still you're definitely going to get
into this I I pre-ordered it already so
I'm going to play it regardless but uh
yeah I mean this is a lot of what I
remember I I think a lot of my friends
are not going to play this version so
that's going to suck my we'll see how
long I last on your mind I have the
finest words in the land uh what about
you are you going to play I'm not I'm
going to play yeah but I'm not sold
yet I I was hoping the stream would just
like convince me like no this is you're
you're getting back in at the right
time it's like good it looks nice it's
very cinematic and kind of cool with
what they do with this but as far
as as something different that I was
kind of hoping for it still feels like
more of the same and very grindy
I like I love getting to do I like I
love when they mix stuff like this oh my
gosh that's loud it's outside of the
just normal like go around and kill
stuff yeah yeah it's this is this helps
a lot this really does help a lot and
just break like I don't but they made me
play for like what an hour and a half
did this and this is just a literal hour
and a half of like go around and kill
these things like a that's my least
favorite thing to
do there's the
tank
I hav even leveled
yet oh wow yeah we're still 90 yeah I
think it I think it averages about 2
hours level back in the day if he did it
m out two shots
oops we didn't try you didn't do many
emotes who me yeah I guess you just have
to watch the video I publish tomorrow
then or are we going to be comparing
emotes yeah in addition to character
model so people will be able to see the
difference between how they look right
uh-huh well actually okay if I get out
of this I'll I'll go ahead and emote a
little
bit looks pretty
good when you were when you were playing
lions and you saw hard did you play on
PVP PVP PVE I'm PVE
pretty is a casual I was going to say
thns are pretty intimidating if you're
on the line I I have I would roll a
bunch of characters cuz I really like
going through the starting zones and
just seeing you know what the
differences are I don't like Toren
because they seem Big Friend Like Big
Friendly cows they're very friendly cows
I don't see they don't seem that
intimidating they're going to provide
some
milk
God I'm just blindly shooting guys I'm
sorry
F's shooting at
me all right
done the guy on the left has he ever
played MMOs have I ever played MMOs I've
played while I think they mean so if
they're looking at the screen I guess
that would be me that is yeah badly I I
play all games but very
badly you've obviously played MOS yeah
that's why I'm
playing SL
l do some slash
cry
sued SL
scared yeah we might be playing this
tomorrow Danny yeah I'm SL dancer
nothing oh okay I'm sorry and some
Danny put some music on put some music
on PO no radio
please actually yeah look how many look
at his face look how his eyes are like I
need a side by side yeah oh if only
there were a side by side video
comparison imagine that imagine that
have you g into the
character y we did no not really kind of
want to see more he definitely looks
like yeah I get it like the face is way
more animated textures on that
fuing does everything else look like
what else has been changed just
everyone's models pretty much everything
else kind of looks not all the models
are changed in the game yet but there's
still
yeah sharper yeah but I mean looking
around this world like this looks like
all the wow this looks like a very
normal slice of the game yeah like the
yeah one of the best parts about wow at
least in the first six years actually
aesthetically it held up really good
like it they the art style like there
hadn't been a cartoony MMO until W came
along like like EQ and everything were
kind of
I don't know realistic yeah yeah
exactly realism yeah and it still fits
like it doesn't I don't feel I don't
feel like it seems like a really old
game always have
one you
can I thought it was cool pretty good
all right I'm gonna let you do your
stream sorry all right we're gonna end
wow we're gonna end it here you want to
wrap it up Justin yeah thanks so much
for for watching guys I know that we are
not the the best MMO players but speak
for yourself yeah I'm not the best MMO
player got did pretty good job you did
you did some awesome MMO and we're going
to probably see a little bit more of
this on the lobby tomorrow if you did
not get quite enough of World of
Warcraft action mm more if you watch mm
more as Danny says and maybe if you want
the chance to to play some of this on
your own and show us how it's really
done uh you should probably tune into
the lobby tomorrow so thanks for
watching now playing with uh World of
Warcraft Warlords of dror thank
you